we're just hearing that uh
sajid javid has resigned
so the health secretary has gone uh he
has been talking uh for a couple of
hours i understand about uh whether or
not he should stay in uh the position
this is of course the second time
that sajid javid has resigned from
government uh sajid javid of course was
an individual who uh resigned uh at the
start of 2020 after boris johnson sought
to uh impose different advisors on him
so effectively sajid javid resigned in
2020 ever appointed principal uh he
believes in himself as being one of the
more principled members of the cabinet
uh and therefore has taken it upon
himself uh to go i know those
discussions have been going on through
the afternoon uh sagittarius i
understand making contact with other
cabinet ministers over the weekend as to
whether or not uh they might talk to him
about their feelings about the boris
johnson government it has always been
the case that should one significant
member of the government decide that
they could no longer put up with the
kind of behaviors
that
frankly uh we've seen from the prime
minister that they're concerned about
that the prime minister is saying then
uh there might be some kind of exodus
now we've waited quite some time there
was a resignation from oliver dowden
after the tiverton holliston by-election
massive defeat for the government but
there was no uh attempts
by others to follow at that point but it
appears today that the resignation uh
six days ago chris pincher perhaps a man
not particularly well known for a job
deputy chief whip that's not
particularly well known uh has ended up
being a turning point because it's gone
right back to that question that we've
had over and over again over the last
six months a year does boris johnson do
the people around boris johnson tell the
truth now saju javid appears this
evening to have concluded that the
answer to that question is no
and has resigned as i say he's been
having those conversations uh earlier
this afternoon he's been saying uh uh
he's been talking to colley's been
reaching out to other cabinet ministers
uh to say that and we do as you can see
on screen have some of the letter um
from boris from sanji javid uh to boris
johnson let me just uh read that through
with you at the moment prime minister he
says from the top he says it was a
privilege to have been asked to come
back into government and serve as
secretary of state for health and social
care it's such a critical time for our
country i've given every ounce of energy
to this task and i'm incredibly proud of
what we have achieved um he talks about
covid and what has been delivered and
the important strides as he puts it in
the recovery and the reform of the nhs
and talks about uh his own uh radical
new approach to areas like dementia and
cancer uh he then goes on to say given
the unprecedented scale of the
challenges in health and social care
it's been my instinct to continue
focusing on this important work
so and here we get to it it is with
enormous regret that i must tell you
that i can no longer in good conscience
continue serving in this government i am
instinctively a team player but the
british people also rightly expect
integrity from their government so sadhu
javed unsheathing uh his weapon in the
letter by talking about integrity
lacking from this government he goes on
the tone you set as a leader and the
values you represent reflect your
colleagues your party and ultimately the
country conservatives at their best are
seen as hard-headed decision-makers
ultimately guided by strong values we
may not have always been popular but we
have been competent in acting in the
national interest sadly in the current
circumstances the public are concluding
that we are now neither the vote of
confidence
the vote of confidence last month shows
that a large number of our colleagues
agree it is a moment for humility grip
and new direction i regret to say
however that it is clear to me that this
situation will not change under your
leadership and you have therefore lost
my confidence too it's three years since
you entered downing street you'll be
credited with seeing off carbonism and
brexit you're very welcome uh uh
uh you've shot a very welcome light on
regional disparities in our country an
agenda that will continue to define our
politic politics uh when i made to
choose between loyalties there can only
be one answer i serve the country first
finally i'd like to put on record my
thanks uh to minister and departmental
colleagues my admiration for the nhs and
social care staff and my love for my
family have been immensely patient the
country needs strong and principled
conservative mps and the party is bigger
than one individual i served you loyally
as a friend and as uh but i served the
country first it also uh i'm told uh i
am getting indications now that other
cabinet ministers are also considering
their position tonight
sajid javid resigns
blasting the prime minister uh for his
uh uh for uh the the situation which he
feels is untenable under boris johnson's
leadership but i understand other
cabinet ministers now tonight also
wondering whether to walk out after
sajid javid senior cabinet ministers
currently having those conversations uh
sajid javid as i say over the weekend
reaching out to other cabinet ministers
but a very big moment uh as other
cabinet ministers now work out whether
they should follow such a javed in one
of the most aggressive resignations
completely different to the one that we
saw from oliver dowden who hinted at the
reasons for his departure but now sajid
javin making an open challenge
significantly increasing the chances
that boris johnson
faces some kind of challenge internal uh
internals in the conservative party over
the coming hours and weeks because
treaties like that that you can see on
screen
saying calling for a moment of humility
grip and new direction clearly thinking
that's not coming from boris johnson
even as he meets at ten past six his
closest allies having spent the
afternoon boris johnson touring the tea
room now meeting his closest allies uh i
think uh will be wondering what happens
next